along with great fame comes great found
him and a long great fandom come weirdos
we have we have we have to discuss this
on the show before I don't know do you
aware of this Johnny Depp that when
Benedict became famous one of the first
things that happened was is fact like
this is so random that his vana decided
that he looked very like an otter are
you aware of this
I'm sorry you would think having a man
to recognize but did we show these four
these are these are the new is it
classic other alter also you know a
creature him and yeah yeah you don't
think about so here's here's a glass as
you what mine would be we may find out
here's a classic officer you know here's
a more expressive officer and see his
neck sorry you would think no how can he
look like this and here you go there he
is
yeah actually one thing yes someone has
a lot of time on their yeah yo it's
annoying them they don't have enough
time on their hands because there aren't
really any more out there so I would you
look for just matching some pictures of
Oscars yeah favor their nose a really
viral and that'll be great
amazing people are like the borrow
pictures of me and Otto would go and see
a film about it okay sorry
you know how this works yeah I'm scared
about it I think you won't be squatchy
this first officer this first heart I'm
afraid does it fire it's the dark side
of the officer Kingdom this is angry ah
sir it made you love order can you do
that can you
okay this this next one is also a
slightly aggressive bottle it's a bit
fist oh it's a bit like yatta other way
they start to get more challenging if I
still get more Challenge over
how can you can you attempt that yeah
okay um so I talked on that way yeah
things I go to that tipper case it's
really wait this is this is an
opportunity for this is not Jesus a
casting for my next role as an auto
really gonna stop yeah this is an
opportunity for myself and Johnny to
channel our inner otter this is a nice
three shot okay if you lean in are
leaning yeah exactly
okay I'll leave it to me oh you're in
the middle minute wait what's the face
on the other okay
now
okay so we go oh that's right but then
then we found this picture we found this
picture of an auction look at this okay
look at this
now we needed a poster of the face of it
you've never seen a happier creature on
planet Earth
look how happy this harder is with his
new teddy bear daddy bear doesn't look
very teddy bear-like depressed I've been
given to an animal I I said that the
command I talked to my phone I went will
need a big teddy bear now however the
big the word big is quite relative yeah
they've gone with a really enormous
teddy bear ready it's over there huh
Oh
but it's it's just there's something I
don't know something about it makes me
want to kind of do
ready
don't kick it there they go to Kyoto
business is over
others
parents are the ones who are slowly
dying she went cuz you know a lot of
girls would be after somebody like
Channing Tatum